bonjour francis monziols
avoue fait la bise ya pas de facs
distanciation ben moi j'ai eu jean
brasse d'accord vous n'avez jamais
arrêté d'embrasser jeu pendant les bras
si cela on brassait je suis surprise
mais vacciner car vous n'êtes pas
vacciné certainement pas vous qui voulez
vous vacciner ne nous imposez pas donc
si vous voulez vous suicidez suite
suicidé vous aujourd'hui je voudrais
rendre hommage aux 250 militants anti
passe vaccinale qui ce week-end ont
encore milité contre le pass vaccinale
qui n'existe plus non mais c'est pas
grave ça me rappelle moi une fois j'ai
largué un mec qui m'avait déjà largué
fait pareil
non mais c'est beau mais on et j'ai
envie de dire aux gens mais faut aller
de l'avant les choses changent il faut
accepter que les choses changent que le
peuple des loups ce gouvernant ainsi par
lui-même
devienne une démocratie
[Musique]
faites ce que je dis
est alors vous mettrez le pouvoir à
l'abri de tout des psychopathes tous les
soirs à 18h vous organiser des apéros
vous invitez vos amis vos voisins vos
parents vos leur présenter notre
programme inventé les apps et russel et
il faut qu'il y en ait pour tout le
monde avec alcool et sans alcool avec
saucisson et sans saucisson et surtout
avec modération imaginez que nous
arrivons à nous multiplier chacun a
multiplié les petits pains comme jésus
c'est merveilleux c'est ce que la
politique c'est
la politique est une passion c'est une
passion extrêmement violente quand on
commence à aimer faut parler c'est le
pouvoir absolu qui rend fou c'est quand
on a pas comme la com quand ce côté-là
ça en fait moi ce que je n'aime pas
c'est quand on n'accepte pas le débat
démocratique par exemple quand on
n'accepte pas de se soumettre à la
contradiction ça c'est le pouvoir comme
je ne l'aiment pas je ne veux plus de
cette gauche qui nous culpabiliser tous
les jours moi je veux une gauche qui
fait plaisir parce que le plaisir c'est
de gauche
je veux dire le jouissez de bosch
c'est totalement absurde
dans mon boxeur ça devient chaud après
y'a pas que le boxer pardon il n'y a pas
que le boxeur avait ya différentes
situations donc un boxeur devient de
jour y a pas que la gastro alors autant
mon seul petit gros mots ya un thé bien
oh oui
crocs oui j'allais prout
[Applaudissements]
apopo à l'étoile de cross elle a dit à
pop au rayon des pailles de crottes ah
oui elle est bien née d'un père le
problème c'est que le pantalon il m'a
l'air transparent et ça
c'est un
oui le popo apparent pas très chic tout
ça est ce que vous aimez votre image est
ce que c'est juste que c'est vous est ce
que oui c'est vraiment moi cette femme
là c'est moins est-ce que vous êtes vous
êtes comment être votre image parce que
là on va vouloir partout dans toutes les
villes de france donc comment vous de
juger cette affiche et vous êtes comment
est ce qu elle vous met mal à l'aise
c'est ce que vous tournez le regard est
ce qu'au contraire vous vous aimez
beaucoup écouté c'est moi voilà et je me
reconnais
donc tu es toi une fois pour toutes à
bout il s'arrête la musique
on a on a liquidé la reine des neiges
vous nous prenez pour un shérif
certainement non bon guignole oui il est
pas cher et monsieur roquet non parce
que c'est plutôt un guignol triste j'ai
jamais dis que c'est un guignol drôle je
peux être ligne free